raise your hand if you feel attacked by
the opposite side
[Music]
step forward if you agree with the
prompt
gender related treatment
should be banned for minors
medical transition is no place for a
child I transition as an adult
and I have medical complications I have
mental health issues child cannot
consent to a medical transition because
kids want they want to eat ice cream
every day it doesn't mean that they
should I kind of agree with you on that
as well because we have so many rules
and regulations when it comes to Tobacco
or alcohol or any type of drugs driving
a car you can't even you know rent a
motel until you're like 25 there's some
specific things that we need to put in
the place that I think would help
protect our children because the miners
themselves really don't know who they
are until they become 25 26 years old
their minds aren't fully developed and
it's just it kind of breaks my heart a
little bit
um so I I did transition as a
as a minor
um you know I was a teenager who had a
lot of mental health issues and had been
sexually exploited and hated my body
and it ended with me
kind of finding spaces where that was
that was twisted into no
you're just a boy in the wrong body and
it ended with me having my first ever
medical intervention being a double
mastectomy at 16 before any hormones
before anything else and because of
transitioning at such a young age in the
past six months I have watched my body
fall apart and waste away in front of me
you know I I have constant joint pain
I've watched my muscle mass waste away
I've watched my vocal cords hurt I don't
know if I'll ever be able to carry a
child
the evidence we have suggests that the
best way to figure out if gender
dysphoria persists into adulthood is to
let them grow up
because a lot of these kids will grow
out of it and many of them will just
grow up and end up being gay or gender
non-conforming yep
real step forward
foreign
major medical organization supports
gender affirming care for Trans youth
absolutely safe and it's life-saving and
there are numerous studies that back
that up the study that backs it up for
Purity blockers is the Dutch protocol
and the same scientists 10 studies that
I can bring to the same scientists that
brought that up have since rolled it
back and said it was never supposed to
be applied the way it has the American
Medical industry we all know is money
hungry and has gone off the rails I I do
agree that there are definitely some
doctors out there that may be taking
advantage of trans people and I'm sorry
that you went through this truly I I
really am sorry but trans kids are valid
and it's not a decision that they're
making right it's health care I want to
speak to that real quick like I came out
13 years ago when I was 14. and I knew
not that I was trans but that I was a
boy I had to go through a lengthy
process of therapy and seeing an
endocrinologist and like go through
different tests and exams to make sure
that this was real to everyone else
involved transitioning and being trans
was just a process I went through to
become who I always knew I was it you
know it wasn't a like decision that I
made it was a life or death thing for me
and if I hadn't gotten on hormones and
gotten surgery at 16 I don't know if I
would be here as a father
um I have I have four kids and so and
also as a trans person I think that um
knowing what it looked like for me as a
child and that experience of going
through all of the turmoil and all of
the trepidation around my gender
identity I would not put my children in
that situation and also I don't think
that surgeries should be allowed for
minors like when we look at the data and
we look at the statistics and we look at
the research the vast majority of these
surgeries are happening to adults
they're not minors so let's start there
right and then further than that if we
look at puberty blockers puberty
blockers
are reversible so when we come to
children when we talk about puberty
blockers that gives them a shot yeah and
it gives them autonomy over their bodies
it gives them a space that they can
explore their expression they can
explore who they are without surgeries
without all of these other things that
could have permanent effects
my kids were maybe eight and ten when I
started my transition and so I talked to
them in kid terms I told my son I said
look you know your mom dad wants to be a
dad because that's how I feel and my
kids being so young they understood it
they were like okay we're with it you
know uh and so as they got older I would
bring them into my world and get them to
understand the things that that maybe I
was going through but now that they're
adults they understand differences in
people not just trans people but people
in general
there is such thing as gender fluid how
do you know that this kid is not going
to change their gender expression later
on we really actually don't have studies
on children that are taken over long
term like over 10 years 20 years you've
only been on Teslas around 14 years one
of the oldest trans men Buck Angel he
almost died from testosterone you're
saying right now it saved your life you
may still die from it you don't know
exactly
a lot of people have died for an
ideology it's not an idea
[Music]
look at the suicide rate of
transmasculine folks is at 55 percent
and one of one of the factors that could
save their lives is support right and so
if we have folks that are committing
suicide because they're not allowed to
transition how do we fix that if you're
telling me the transition the first for
children or minors is something that's
that that shouldn't be done the first
here I am very I am very sensitive to
this subject as I've been the person who
has had to talk people off the ledge
when it comes to suicidality
the discussion around how we talk about
suicide is a very dangerous one in this
community you know my parents were told
do you want a dead daughter or a living
son that's not an appropriate way to
talk about that and I understand that
but it is our trans masculine youth I
understand that are at the highest I
understand that and they deserve help
but we also need to have a responsible
conversation that is not using suicide
as a means to push them down a pipeline
before they have that comprehensive care
so I have a question so Aries I know
you've been wanting this yeah I know
because I have a big problem I know I'm
not an interrupter what I'm going to say
is we insult children our youth so much
by taking away their autonomy and their
own agency over their own decisions and
insulting that they know who they are
like an adult knows who they are more
than they do no one knows who I am more
than I do and it's always been that way
I've always known who I was I've never
felt like I was in the wrong body
um I just had to adjust my body and so I
think taking away kids agents see and
the right to their own body is um
it's just it's anti-human I have a
question do you believe minors should be
able to get tattoos or plastic surgery
or consent to the list of other ideas
to what level do we give children
a bodily autonomy over everything they
do because here's the thing children
need barriers in childhood development
you need barriers and they need a safe
way to push against those barriers and I
worry with the current medical system
that instead of giving them a safe way
to express themselves and push against
barriers we have taken some of those
barriers away and that is why you see
more D transitioners because those
barriers have been lifted they're not
just Doling out surgeries for children
that's not happening I had a letter from
a therapist in a single visit at the
gender Clinic office
from that therapist who did not
psychoanalyze
yeah their issues weren't being trans
there were a lot of other issues I have
a diagnosis of gender dysphoria so you
shouldn't you were misdiagnosed right
yeah you had to get a second opinion
honey right
how was I supposed to do that when my
parents were told but your parents your
parents their biggest their biggest
crime in all this was trusting a medical
system that they thought would help me
and the professionals apparently not
doing the right thing here I understand
but your parents were responsible for
the decisions that were made on your
behalf I think that what this
what the sites is the importance of you
sharing your story be because what it
shows is that you can't jump into these
Transitions and you shouldn't listen to
these doctors that push you to
transition just because you're feeling a
certain way
social media brainwashes teens to
believe that they're trans
I have like I have to agree on that one
like there's this thing about it right
like yeah there's this there's this play
that they have I don't think that it
necessarily
brainwashes children but I think there
are a lot of people who get into being
queer or trans because it's a it's it
it's trendy and I know that's a really
controversial statement to make as a
trans person but I have seen it I've
experienced it and I also find that
social media especially apps like Tick
Tock give a lot of these kids
so much misinformation and lead to
people thinking they're trans when there
are much deeper issues and everyone just
wants to belong and find an identity
especially when they're young and I
think I think brainwash is such a strong
word
that's why I hesitated to step forward
and that's why I would step in and
actually say it's more sort of like a
social contagious yeah yeah what got me
to transition in the first place was
social media they had a grasp on me that
there could be something else out in the
world for me during that Discovery and I
played it to the fullest 100 I even
passed as a female for a good you know
what was it five six years out of the
seven that I was a transition that
transition and
later down the road I went and paid out
of pocket and talked to a just a regular
therapist and she made me start
questioning my own existence in a way
what I can do as a human being not just
as you know a male or a female but what
can I contribute to the society and it
made me open up to
maybe I was I was born as a male and it
feels empowering to me
yeah I mean I was heavy on social media
like in my transition Tumblr that was
the place to be for sure and everyone
was talking about their transition from
my experience and everyone was talking
about a lot of mental health issues
depression and all that and it was kind
of being trendy in that sense like when
Tick Tock came out like that was like a
whole nother world and the biggest thing
that I found with that is like they
weren't saying a lot of the negative
things that were happening in their
transition there was always like a
positive outlook on it like I'm being
who I who I need to be like this is
great take it to your happiness yeah and
I sold like so much on social media like
I made a documentary on my transition
and I really went into depth of like a
lot of my depression that I dealt with
on that and I didn't find anyone talking
about that Jen I personally didn't think
I was trans until I saw earlier trans
YouTubers before I was just gender
bending men and for sure I also feel
like comparing yourself on social media
to other people that are more beautiful
and successful will create dysphoria of
some kind but some people will affect
yourself damage for sure because we see
feels as beautiful trans woman that are
all dolled up or had every possible
plastic surgery they could ever get
you're gonna feel dysphoric you're going
to be like I don't look like that you
know what I mean whether your sister
trans everyone so social media it has
such a bad impact I wanted to be that
muscular dude and I wanted to do that so
yeah it is such a bad like well
documented bad impact on people's like
sense of like sense of self and mental
health and so but I also really quickly
just want to say like I don't want
people to think that like
social media is turning people trans
all right can the disagree a step
forward
yeah okay so my thoughts on social media
and everyone suddenly looking or being
trans
um I think whoever is leaning towards
that or looking towards that or looking
towards being trans for answers was
always someone that felt that way or
felt some type of way about their gender
or their Identity or the way they
present themselves
they're just going to go that way I know
plenty of Femme twinks who went the
muscle queen pipeline it's not a rare
occurrence and so just experience your
life have fun try not to take social
media seriously because no one is
advertising their failures it's all fake
yeah but I think it is also important to
say that like social media is very very
effective you know I mean I personally
scroll in Tick Tock I'm like do I have
OCD do I have autism like all these
different things like I can't suck you
in so it's important to be aware of
those things I have a question for
Samantha since you have the largest
platform here I do believe over the
years you've inspired people to
transition
yeah I do yeah I think that I've
inspired people to believe that it's
okay to be transgender it's okay to
express themselves and that it's
possible to live a happy and successful
life how do you feel about the fact that
some of them are going to regret the
body modifications they got I'm going to
have like I think that they should go to
a doctor that is well versed in gender
care and have the appropriate
um psycho analytic analysis done
beforehand that's not bad I feel like a
lot of folks are going to social media
looking for possibility models they're
looking to see if they're okay I know
for me when I was when I was very young
looking to see if there were other
people like me because for a long time I
thought that I was the only one exactly
right and so feeling like that like
suicide was was a thing for me right and
so when I did see a possibility modded
when I did see somebody that looked like
me that put me in a space where I was
like I'm okay sigh Everly right I will
say there's also a difference from like
showing people that you can have a
positive life and then telling them what
to do so I think you on your channel are
kind of like hey look what I was able to
do and how this made me feel versus like
you should do this because I did this
right and also I try my best to be very
upfronted because we can't help but
someone could change their mind on
something like that's inevitable yeah
we're humans and I have to jump on one
more thing with that like if I'm
watching her Channel and it inspires me
to transition I have been watching white
straight men be president for years and
I've not wanted to be president once so
I don't identify with that we're going
to talk about brainwashing let's talk
about where we see things every single
day happening a certain way versus
someone just living their life
authentically people with gender
dysphoria need therapy not surgery
it's potentially both though yeah I
think everyone's gender dysphoria needs
to go through a therapeutic process and
Mental Health Care before they make that
choice for themselves exactly I
personally confuse a lot of my gender
dysphoria for body dysmorphia because no
matter how much I feminize my body so
today I still don't feel comfortable in
my own body and now like looking among
like members of trans Community I see
that people keep on getting more and
more surgeries the surges are no longer
affirming you can just tell that this
person is like struggling with body
Images I was able to get an estrogen
pretty quickly when I was 22 and my
mental health declined afterwards and I
attributed it to being still in the
wrong body and needing more body
modification I end up getting sex or
assignment surgery I do believe that
transition was sold to me as a hardware
fix for my mental issues that were not
addressed I still struggle with
internalized homophobia pushed me into
transition in the first place I
struggled with borderline personality
disorder body dysmorphia I'm on a
spectrum my name is then I have all
these issues that were not helped and I
was still struggling with them after
transition and I still do overall after
a few years I came to a conclusion that
I was not in the wrong body that I'm a
gender non-conforming man and I am a
feminine man that's what I am
I I don't know if you guys have heard
but I've had a lot of binary trans
people say that it's not a mental health
issue like if you're trans and I know I
don't agree with that like I think
there's a disconnect between the mind
and the body I guess I'm asking that
like it's like you think that it's a
mental health disorder I don't think
being transgender is a mental disorder I
think you know gender incongruence is
what they're referring to it as now um
it's listed as a sexual health concern
but the gender dysphoria which is the
symptom that arises when you are
transgender is a mental health concern
so maybe I'm thinking of like that's
what I'm trying to say then and then
once you are diagnosed with gender
dysphoria and I feel like this is kind
of what the prompt is kind of hinting at
if you do have gender dysphoria the only
treatment for that is transition whether
that be just a social transition a
medical transition whatever transition
fits you that is the only way to heal
your gender dysphoria when I
transitioned the first thing my mom said
to me was can't you just be gay
um it hurt hearing that but a big reason
that she said that was she was afraid of
what my dad would think
um he's always been very very
conservative very traditional you could
say you would make comments about trans
people about gay people growing up so I
always knew that he wasn't necessarily
accepting
um
so when it came down to me transitioning
I said to him I'm going to do this
either you're going to be the dad that
accepts me and supports me through it or
like goodbye
um and he chose to support me and we're
closer than ever now
and I think a lot of us go through
medical transitions to easier go through
social transition definitely right and
so a lot of our folks that do Transition
and made the transition both both
experiences are valid but also
um understanding that we're we're not
mentally ill because we're trans
and I think that there should be a
psychiatrist or someone in within
Behavioral Health to be able to say okay
you're in the right frame of mind to
make this decision but I I want to just
make it very clear that trans people are
not dealing with mental health because
they're trans absolutely I disagree I
feel like transgender is definitely an
elderly trans people afford for it to be
classified at mental illness so it's
covered by Insurance otherwise why are
you getting the surgeries to because
it's not a medical condition dysphoria
is a medical condition it is but it's in
your head you I would say that you have
some kind of mental disorder if you're
trying to mimic a stereotype of opposite
sex
mental illness is to transition I have a
question though because I have a
gendered dysphoria diagnosis I always
have
but I'm still where I am today can I
give you my honest opinion
I think that you were probably
misdiagnosed I don't think I was so do
you feel dysphoria in your body I
certainly do now yeah me too
what you want to talk about now but at
the time I at the time at the time I
genuinely believed I did I thought it
would save me and then looking back I
realized that my dysphoria stemmed from
some severe trauma that was not handled
and that's why I think that mental step
like mental health step is so important
yeah because I've heard this from
several other you know most mostly
female D transitioners who we had some
form of pretty bad trauma that spawned
genders Fourier symptoms yeah and we we
can disagree about this diagnosis
something really but it felt real time
for me and I'm sure it did I didn't mean
it no I know I know I know I know
um and it's one of those things where
that's where the mental health treatment
really needs to come in and get to the
root of that issue because oftentimes
specifically with the do transitioners
I've talked to
that was ignored you know I I came out
to my parents in a mental health
facility after telling the therapist
that I thought I was transgender
and she told me we had to tell your
parents so that way you can get the help
you need it led to me seeing a gender
therapist who
honestly the issues I was facing were
never addressed to this day no one ever
addressed the fact that I had severe
like trauma and exploitation going on as
a young teenager instead I was kind of
just affirmed in you believe this and
instead of
even just a little pushback
it led me to the point where the the
very first medical intervention I ever
had was a double mastectomy at 16. a few
months after that I started testosterone
because it was the next step of what I
was supposed to do
God intended for there to be only two
genders
okay you go first okay so as a Christian
I truly believe that God created male
and female and he had created that
throughout life throughout the nature
throughout the wildlife throughout you
know Earth itself and then the arguments
come up into the ocean sides of well
there's these asexual creatures and
stuff like that well they were designed
that way for a reason and we humans were
not designed to
uh we were designed to procreate and be
able to bring life back to the Earth
because we live and we die and we live
and we die we it's a rotation of a
process of life in itself and it's its
own Journey so I truly still believe
that there is mail and there is female
but I can respect people's choices
however that's where I stand on it
well I'm not Christian but I do believe
there's only two biological Sexes and
somehow that's how it's been designed
whether it's by higher power or by
Evolution I do believe gender expression
has been on a spectrum for centuries so
we do have references to people who've
been cross-dressing we have references
to Unix and as somebody who went through
a transition and detransition when I
started taking testosterone it's almost
like reminded me of my original
blueprint and I feel like I went against
my original blueprint and I did a lot of
damage to it and I just cannot go back
to who I was because without my
testicles I'm just too far gone in my
transition
so that's where I'm at
in the disagree step forward
[Music]
yeah you know we have historically spent
more time focusing on and celebrating
several genders there are several
different cultures throughout the world
that that celebrate the different
genders and to negate the fact that they
exist and to negate their their validity
is just wrong there are as many intersex
people as there are red-headed people on
the planet I can name 12 people at the
top of my head who are born intersex so
to pretend like there's man and woman is
just erasing an entire group of people
the god you speak of the first God that
intersects people get to meet is the
doctor because it's up to their
discretion of just what you're going to
be when they mutilate their body to be a
man or a woman and that is not fair
right right and I think also gender and
male and female is not the same thing
yeah we're talking about gender which is
like gender gender identity the social
aspects to being a man or woman but male
and female dictate sex body parts I
disagree with the having sex and gender
being two different things I believe
them to be one so I I believe that there
is
um they're the same they're one and the
same they're not different but we have
evolutionary problems within the
humanity because I also see that there
are intersex intersex animals that do
exist but and that's how they're born
but I also do believe that the initial
design was for man and woman and then
somewhere along the way viruses
mutations diseases uh plagues all that
type of stuff that we have in the world
does play A Part back onto our onto the
world itself but I believe the initial
intent was for God to create Adam and
Eve not Adam and Steve I'm just gonna
say it that's homophobic I know it
sounds homophobic and I understand it is
I grew up in a very homophobic family
and since I was a kid I was always
brainwashed sad gay is bad my parents
were not happy that I was naturally
feminine they always try to make me more
masculine they try to give me to
masculine Sports I was mercilessly
bullied at school for my femininity
constantly being told that I'm not a
real man that I'm a [__] and when I
came out to my parents as gay
um they took me to therapist and tried
to do pretty much conversion therapy
which failed so I don't believe in God I
believe in people that exist right in
front of me and I believe they should
have the right to exist and so I'm not
saying they don't have the right to
exist but I mean just saying that I mean
they want mistakes either they're just
here the way you and I are here right
now and they are who they are and we
have to accept people as they are right
and they are biological biological
differences in trans folks when we look
at the brain stem you know our brain
stems are different like that's
neurologically right neurologically
we're we're different yeah and male and
female are different exactly trans
people are different yes they've found a
distinct difference in the the cortex
there is no no there is no biomarker for
Trans some rearing scan of some gay
males is identical to female brain but
there is no biomarker for Trans please
don't spread them there are signs that
hints towards it it's just not confirmed
there's research under the belief that
there is but there there's no scientific
fact to back that up which therefore I
believe that God's initial attempt was
to create male and female if God
intended to if God exists and in the way
that you believe and just intended to
make male and female then we wouldn't be
sitting here I believe I believe
intersection in a higher power right of
my own and and God is not this thing
that creates rules and binary situations
and laws that can be broken or really
made we're just all here yeah you know
like I was born in a female body but I
was never a girl never ever ever I can't
explain why but that is
the my truth that is the fact that is
who I've always been and there's no way
that I'm gonna look up at this guy at
some God and be like oh yeah you made me
as a mistake
positioning improved my sex life
who wants a star I could start and I'm
embarrassed
um not to say to my sex life was any it
was bad before but I think
transitioning and coming into my body
and feeling comfortable in my skin
allowed me to open up more and allowed
me to not only be better in bed but also
explore what my sexuality looks like
yeah being trans is also like
made sex really complicated for me too
because I'm like I'm a straight guy and
I'm very I pass very well and majority
of the women that I've been with I would
have to eventually kind of like break it
to them that I was trans and deal with a
lot of rejection and with somebody I
would never let girls touch me or see me
without clothes on not having a penis
made me feel inferior as a man and that
no one would want me which is why I like
rejected that part of myself and never
even let it be loved it took a lot of
really accepting that people were going
to accept me and be attracted to me and
love me and want to give me pleasure
regardless of what was in my pants and
that took a long time it took until I
was like I think I was 21.
um when my ex-girlfriend and I started
dating from that point on I I realized
that just letting someone love me was
half the battle and once I let that
piece come into play I mean it changed
my life
um
do you want to go you want to go
so even though I do transitioned um
in the beginning especially when I was
on hormones like it increased my sex
drive a lot and there were a lot of
aspects to that that was like enjoyable
to explore my fluidity for sure I was
able to date a lot of people and I think
like from detransitioning it's like the
opposite of that like my sex drive
completely changed
um in a way that like
there's good aspects to not being horny
24 7. um it helped me be more
comfortable in my body even with
detransitioning which sounds weird but
like having a trans male body was like
so different from the norm so like I had
to accept certain parts of myself so
like even with detransitioning it helps
me accept like certain parts of myself
that I don't have still absolutely I did
identify as a gay man before I
transitioned and like those
relationships I feel like I always kind
of had like out of body experiences when
we were like intimate and even after I
transitioned before I had bottom surgery
I like just like anxiety and the
dysphoria that I would feel whenever I
was intimate or like a partner would try
to be intimate with me was just like
crippling yeah um so then when I had
surgery and I felt more affirmed in my
body and you know everything is it feels
right to me now I'm finally able to have
those intimate connections with people
and you know form those deeper bonds so
it's really helped me a lot I'm so happy
for you that's amazing thanks yeah of
course when I came out as trans when I
was 18 I moved to Miami and
um it wasn't until I got my gender
affirming surgeries where I was uh like
where I did like lose my virginity
because I was just not comfortable doing
that I was like I'm not presenting in my
best light and I think I could get there
yeah it felt weird and and you also
attract a different type of partner back
in my day I used to attract what we call
a chaser versus someone who was
genuinely attracted to the female form
which is someone who I wanted to like
that's the role I felt and so that's
where I was comfortable and now I'm
comfortable in Virginia like Virginia
the t word did not exist that was on
Jerry Springer and Maury Povich and
that's where that stayed no one no one
was trans and so I transitioned uh when
I was about 18 I moved to Miami and my
joke is that I hit the tarmac and I said
I'm a woman by the way I remember I came
out to my mom and I was super nervous
because I'd come out as gay years and
years before because that was so much
easier but when I came out I remember my
mom just asked if I was happy if I was
healthy and if I was going to finish
school because she had already paid for
it
and I said yes
can the disagree step forward
um transition definitely ruined my sex
life I was fine with my penis but a year
after estrogen I felt like that part
didn't belong on me anymore
so I went ahead and had sex for
assignment surgery
after that my sex drive was gone pretty
much I kept on having complications
I wasn't able to keep my new Vagina open
despite rigorous dilation I had multiple
revisions including co-imaginoplasty I
just got some of my sex drive back last
year when I started transitioning with
testosterone but it's kind of traumatic
to have male sex drive back without my
penis
also I want to say that sexuality is
fluid my sexuality has definitely
changed once I lost my testosterone
before I was strictly attracted to men
after I lost my testosterone I was
attracted to people in general because
now I didn't have this like male sex
drive so I couldn't relate to men as
much you know as I wanted to have sex
but I just wanted to hold hands and
cuddle and now my body dysmorphia slash
actual gender dysphora as well as worse
than ever before I do feel like I'm
stuck in a surgically created body I
just don't think I've been really Myself
by trying to become a woman yeah so
transition did take a lot from me
must be really really hard yeah it's
okay yeah
can I ask you a question yeah sure
um
if you had like found the results that
you desired at the beginning would you
feel differently than you do now
um no because I realized I just missed
being a man you know I just miss being
obsessed About Sex and Money I don't
want to do the whole emotional thing and
I'm talking about stereotypes okay so I
regret it's just like now medical
patient for life also having sex or back
it just reminds me that I lost all these
years I could have been having fun
whether it's Chasers or I definitely
have internalized homophobia so internal
homophobia also pushed me into
transition because I felt like Chasers
weren't good enough because I wanted to
be a woman I wanted to escape my
homosexuality but now I realize at the
end of the day I'm a gay man and I'm
still living with internalized
homologous therapists actually never
helped me with that
it's fascinating that you say that
because
I dated men and women and in my
transition I felt like I had an
internalized homophobia when I was with
men because I didn't feel like a gay man
and that was really hard for me to like
figure out because I had
had this journey for so long and a lot
of sexual experiences were good but I
was on Grindr and I'm sleeping with
these men and they're treating me how I
would want to be treated in a social
setting but I'm like I was really really
masculine in my presentation but I
tended to be kind of feminine in my
roles um within sex and so I think that
also got me to realize that I wanted to
transition because it was a reflection
of the relationships that I had like to
follow kind of some stereotypes like I
did miss being a woman in some of those
like social settings like with how women
interacted with me with how men
interacted with me like so yeah that's
heavily relatable to that for sure so I
do not regret my transition shocking I
know that was like a really great time
for me in the beginning I really was
able to explore and express myself in
ways that I could not have done without
hormones and surgery I learned so much
about how people treat people based on
gender and looks in general I feel like
I would not be the person especially the
confidence and security that I have
within my self if I didn't transition as
presenting as a woman in this world my
Dynamic with men in general is so much
different I mean I was very insecure
very submissive very quiet and now I'm
able to speak up for myself because of
that yeah um I was actually going to say
uh during my transition I didn't
actually have a high sex drive from the
hormones and ever since I came back my
sex drive has been higher ever since and
I think it's because I'm no longer on
the estrogen why testosterone levels are
increased after I changed back to being
who I was originally born as and it also
kind of opened up my eyes to say maybe I
wasn't really a female this is probably
what I would like my my future spouse to
have to look upon it and I just I'm
proud that I actually have that sex
drive back again because I felt like I
lost it for a long time
the lgbtq plus Community is not as
accepting as they claim
s physical chairs yeah yeah I'm
embarrassed to agree with this true
information there's still so much
transphobia within the LGB people in the
LGBT community that um hasn't been
addressed yet shoot there's transphobia
within trans people
when I was transitioning in high school
I searched for acceptance from the CIS
hetero world and now I feel like I'm
doing the opposite and searching for
acceptance for my own Community half the
time like when I was in college the
queer community on my campus hated me
because I did like
heteronormative like guy stuff I played
lacrosse I was in a frat but like I
wasn't that guy I guess that they had in
their head and I every time I would go
to the LGBT club meetings I would get
like
like they would stare into my soul like
I was just this awful thing and it's
always just made me feel invisible and
small in whatever space I'm in and I
find that just really disheartening and
it happens in a lot of other cultures
and communities as well too so it's
funny that it just happens you mentioned
like the transitioning in high school
part and like that shift from
you know searching for acceptance
outside and then turning around and then
having to search for acceptance within
the community yeah because I I did
notice that when I was still living as a
trans man when you know when I I passed
really well all of a sudden it was like
I wasn't welcome in these spaces anymore
until they knew and then you get that
that icky feeling of like you only want
me here because of that yeah and you
know now I have the the d-trans aspect
with no Community wants me no one like I
I'm still part of the LG I'm part of the
LGB part but I've lost people that I
thought they'd liked me for me and it
didn't matter
what I was right
but then all of a sudden detransitioning
was the thing that
that they I've been called a traitor
yeah me too you know it's me too they
don't want me the rest of the world
doesn't want me that's not true that's
not true
yeah but it feels really isolated like
this is not a club
and it's not like a personality trait
that I'm just taking up and
God forbid one day I changed my mind I
won't but like or something happens
where I have to detransition I would
hope that the people who stood by my
side through everything else would still
be there for me because of who I am
period and not because of an effing
label over my head and even when I
transitioned I dealt with the traitor uh
to everyone it was you know oh you want
to be a man and the patriarchy and I was
like I get it but also yeah
but what I found very interesting was
like this this
divide between trans men and trans women
when I first started doing a lot of
advocacy I was told that just being in
the space that I was taking up too much
room that I was taking up too much space
and don't speak and and all of these
things and I was like wait a minute but
I'm I'm trans too right this community
also belongs to us too so that was
something that I grappled with for a
while I
hung out with a lot of gay women and
then when I transitioned I definitely
lost my space there and that was like
really hard for me to navigate because
being shunned out of these
female spaces for me was really hard and
difficult and then when I got to the
transmill community there was a lot of
competition who looked the best who
passed the best like that was very
difficult oh yeah shoot fortunately I
had a full beard
like yeah you know what I mean like but
still like I heavily resonate with trans
men still and I definitely resonate with
trans women from detransitioning and
gender non-conforming people so it's
like where do I belong weird position to
be in because it's like one Community
like I said doesn't really want you but
you don't fit in you can't really go all
the way back so you don't fit in with
the rest of them we just shouldn't have
to categorize like we shouldn't have to
float around wonder where we
belongs but even then we're all still
vastly different individuals who have
vastly different life experience
political views religious beliefs right
you know
experience right in some ways it's
empowering because it feels like you're
even though all this happened you're
being seen as an individual school for
almost the first time after
you know spending my high school years
being lumped in
by both the LGBT community and the rest
of the people in in a category
but it's also very isolating because you
don't have really that Community Support
that other places get
bye yeah
thank you guys so much
fantastic it's great to talk to all of
you
[Music]